Chris you've got some NFL headlines over
there Cora do I do before we get to the
first one of Edward or reporting on the
latest on the Ezekiel Elliott contract
hold out the name of Ezekiel Elliot's
agent is rocky Arsenal yes okay can you
put up the photograph of Marshall with
rocky Arsenal please for those who want
to know how tight you are with this man
it was at the Pro Football Hall of Fame
you chose him as your a presenter hmm
he was your agent for all those years
correct do my agent still your agent
right now yep good old rocky I've always
enjoyed what hanging with him the boat
games were the worst at the only hope
he's a better agent and I think he is
great man love him and so also put up a
photograph of Voe how back far back you
go with Ezekiel Elliott oh yeah you go
way back back yet look right there where
was this that's uh that's in the Tiger
Woods Center up at Nike Nike
headquarters you see here's he like see
he was a junior in high school when we
met and he was at the Nike opening look
at him yeah I've known him since since
he was 16 now a grown-ass man yes as we
like to say the NFL business all right
Eduardo's up tweet let's put that up
right here on the Rich Eisen show this
is about 10 minutes ago sources the most
recent offer negotiations between the
holdout Ezekiel Ellie and the Cowboys
came from the team Eliot has been
offered a contract making him one of the
NFL's two highest for a second
highest-paid running back that would
suggest the team's offering his more
than levy on bail and less than Todd
Gurley anything he would sounds good to
me okay
but it sounds good in terms of accurate
or sounds good to what Zeke would be
worth I mean I haven't checked in today
okay was when I was coming up this
morning I didn't check in okay to see
what their latest offer was but um you
know it's uh I'd say it's close okay you
would say it's close between between hey
and and the Cowboys or or because right
now I mean it you know rocky told Mort I
mean he he told Chris Mortensen we did
not find the joke of Zeke who funny at
all even though Jerry Jones when he said
Zeke ooh
after Tony Paulette had an excellent
game against the Rams in Hawaii did say
that Pollard in his mind was a
complement to Zeke when Zeke returns
that Zeke would need some time to be
obviously spelled and Pollard is gonna
be terrific if that was essentially what
he had to say yeah so he fixed it he did
he fixed it but when you when you are
the owner of men you can say all of that
that's that's like people accept that
that's fine it's okay but it did not
land as a joke with no it's not a do
within a joke to me either
well why I'm just saying when you are
the owner right of men you can say those
things you're allowed to you you
actually think that it's okay and it's
acceptable but it is not no not at all
what's uh what's for those who might sit
there and Jerry's Jerry's a grown man
himself and if someone joked about him
being kinda a second a second fiddle
owner he'd take that personal - mm-hmm
so you know you'd when you to start
running back of a team or start playing
on a team and your owner is making these
statements that players that are beneath
you are of the same quality I mean it it
rubs you the wrong way honestly and you
know me you know me we go away I didn't
think he said that Zeke is beneath me I
didn't see III didn't get that I got him
having lowly I got him as it's probably
a guy who was just genuinely no he was
saying fired up about seeing this kid
ball out right he was asked to come Zeke
and he any joked like Zeke who and then
and then followed it up with a serious
answer let's just get to it
sure Jerry needs this kid or anybody at
the running back position to go out
there and perform because if they had a
show if the showing and the running game
is not good the pressure to sign Zeke
becomes greater we've been through this
before
like we watched it last year we levy on
Bill Pittsburgh Steelers fine yeah James
Conner he's gonna do great now I think
James Conner is
James Connor very serviceable running
back can you do something yeah can you
get in there and be held accountable
yeah but can he win games for you
did distillers make the playoffs no they
did not know and part of the reason
though is he had a high ankle sprain at
the end of the year and they had to go
with their third string guy Connor was 2
was terrific
who cares being available is being
available that is true that that's it
when you're not available you're not but
here's the difference and I love playing
devil's advocate with you is please do
okay that the difference is is Le'Veon
wasn't under contract Zeke is is he
willing to just forego paychecks because
that's that's that's clearly the the
midnight that that Jerry Jones is
thinking is coming closer and closer and
closer and as long as that gets closer
Izzy quilling to miss paychecks hanging
out in Kabul yeah how many days are we
till the season start the Cowboys play
their first game in 17 days 17 days of
suspense we are going to find out so
right now there's like I can't I can't
show those cards rich I mean okay it is
what it is and and and if if the Cowboys
want to find out if he's willing to miss
game checks then we shall find out the
question is are they willing to to
bargain or or gamble with maybe not
having him and maybe not not winning a
Super Bowl this year or having a chance
at winning the NFC ES or whatever that
looked like
or better yet having that be out there
without Zeek to find out what kind of
quarterback is Dec all of those things
are you know it's yeah we will find out
there's there's a lot there's a lot the
risk on both sides and it is what it is
is not is not
dekes fault that he's in this situation
there's something wrong with out with
the system when just because you were
drafted first you get this fifth year
tagged on and then you have to play this
extra year and when a guy who may be
drafted in the second or third round he
has four years let's tack I'm just
saying it he has more
leveraging you Wow that's this just see
you can never build a perfect system and
and every time we get close to like the
CBA being done these little issues start
to come up with things that need to be
fixed well I'm sitting you're thinking
if my contract with the NFL network was
up and there was a situation where the
boss of NFL Network had a microphone in
front of him and he said rich who after
a really good show that I wasn't hosting
I would not find that funny yeah yeah
when it's your work I would not I would
not find it's just not funny yeah I need
the proverbial Snickers we know that we
know that Jerry understood woody what he
did now and I guarantee you rich these
things it's just it's just it's weird
they are the Cowboys in every preseason
game that ezq Elliott is not there they
are going to run the football well Jason
Garrett has we run the football well
they are going to run the ball well so
to button this up the dreaded poke
question is time to ask this of Marshall
Faulk there's only two answers yes
you cannot give an it is what it is okay
can't get it is what it is there's two
answers to this poll question Chris
Brockman get asking the poll question
Marshall after week one will rich be
eating del two foes hat because Zico
Elliott is still holding out am i eating
a hat rich you will be eating a hat and
and I'm only saying this because we have
history here Jerry has done this before
he's played this game with Emmitt Smith
he played it two games and who games
into the season and and that's a that's
a fact and right now in the cowboys they
are they're in a position that that they
have to try to reset the market they
have to on every position because salary
cap wise they didn't do a good job so
they have to reset the market it's not
our fault is he in the majority of this
poll question results so far
yes yes 61% and you know Delta folks
just gonna wear that hat working out and
all that stuff has dirt on this mic wear
that hat and I believe is it a free app
but it's a dirty yeah yeah you know
Callaway's our sponsor but you know my
to that yeah that's yeah you didn't pay
that no do you have anything on it you
nothing at all right now Mike dr. folk
Mike anything that you have on that you
actually I always have to look shirts I
bought the shorts you bought the shorts
are you sure my shorts for me they got
back Marshall Faulk here on the Rich
Eisen show what what other news items do
we have over there first some other
things a big growing situation in
Indianapolis Marshall where you know
quite well Andrew Luck still not
practicing Frank Reich said on Tuesday
that the issue with his ankle is a
matter of full speed movement verse pain
threshold the team ideally wants to know
his status before by week one before
next Monday which is 13 days shadow what
do you think of that it's just amazing
and um you know I'm a fan of Lutz but
man he does not he does not get the same
treatment that rg3 goods what do you
mean
I mean he's often injured not available
broke the ladder interceptions in big
game make you been through you've been
verb you've been you've been verbally
lobbing here so far but you notice where
it is going you gotta yell Jeff Andrew
Locke has been to an AFC Championship
game Andrew Luck one and done to the
Houston Texans last year or the team
that nobody thought could do anything I
mean Andrew Luck has had a chance rich
and RG through he's not given a chance a
he's given a chance so what is your
point here man he was given a chance
that's it do you think let's ask this
question then do you think a quarterback
that does not practice at all in the
third preseason week on a situation that
involves his ankle has the ability to
start week one yes okay we're not we're
not there's not we're not a second one
right now the game is different and and
just how the coaches are coaching and
and what they are doing
I'd be worried if this was your one sure
under Frank Wright that
this would be different but I mean it's
it's not it's not a big deal now speed
of the game hmm
obviously seeing it in real time it
helps but but if you think about I mean
with the Rams it last year and they
barely played their starters and and
right you go out and you you know you
try to simulate game action and you try
to control the action and that's I think
that's where the league is going when
you say barely played their starters do
you mean Todd Gurley in the NFC
Championship game Marshall same thing
weekend what is going on with that name
Todd Gurley it's a good question rich I
wish I had the answer but if it's if
it's anything like what I had it's just
something that you have to manage what
did what did you have you I had my
meniscus was was degenerative and it
doesn't grow back it's just going to
continue to wear down you know it's like
brick pets in a sense you know if and
the more you use it the you know the
less you're going to have and that
cushion as it starts to disappear it
cause swelling in the knee right so you
really have to manage your knee you
really have to there's a lot of
treatment in ice and and I think that's
where it I shouldn't say I think if
that's where Todd is then it's something
that he has to manage well you know
McVeigh obviously very well being close
to the Rams organization you being
Marshall Faulk he's a smart guy do you
think that they're gonna still ride him
in the same way that they did for the
first 12 weeks of the season last last
year was different because you have to
look at the backups that they lost I
mean they had to get CT astronaut the
street yes sir
so by losing backups you can't have guys
in the game that you can't depend on in
the passing game and in the hole
protection aspect of it so they have
browned what do you think of the rookie
yeah to get the kid from Oklahoma's yeah
right I like what they've done and
they've gotten some some help in the
backfield some guys that and if they can
stay healthy in the backfill if they're
to stayed healthy in the backfield
this wouldn't would not have been an
issue for him but they couldn't they
they did not so they go in a full
complement with these three guys
then we won't see girly touch it what 30
times a game like we did some say that I
still think you're going to see because
if you look at the pace that he was on
the Rams do a great job at not just
running him into the middle of the line
of scrimmage they create matchup
situations and a lot of their times
it's it's he has to make a safety mess
or a linebacker miss and he's off to the
races
so it's not like he's taking a pounding
they spread things out and run the ball
they contain things and throw the ball
they do a lot of different stuff but you
need him in there because because he's
the nightmare
he's the mismatch and in the Super Bowl
the fact that that they he wasn't
available fully right against arguably
the greatest probably chess game player
and Bill Belichick when you have an off
when you want to stop an offense I mean
that it was like you made it so easy for
him yeah yeah you're like you get it you
got a running back tied behind your back
yeah it was like oh Rocky Anderson's
back there they're running
he's only he can't hurt us in the
passing game and that was it
Marshall Faulk here in the Rich Eisen
show hit him up with another one over
there okay
former Browns coach Hugh Jackson huge
profile about him in Sports
Illustrated's NFL preview coming out the
big quote you're gonna suck you have a
question with their choice of subject
I'm not sure but the big quote that
you're seeing right now is Hugh saying
he's not a loser it's not who he is all
the losses in Cleveland ate him up kept
him up and what Bagas een Sports
Illustrated like does he have a friend
there well Silver's not there anymore
but I'm just trying to figure this out
not oh no disrespect to you it sounds
like you are actually disrespecting him
I gotta be honest with you I'm just
wondering how did he get this interview
I think they're just reflecting on how
poorly last year went for him he lost a
couple of family members was fired from
Cleve oh okay after only a couple of
wins he did admit he failed tremendously
but noted how it so she's not being
liked
people time dot Sports Illustrated right
what am I in my minute it might be an
insensitive to you know what Marshall
I'm gonna I'm gonna be the host here I'm
gonna know are you imma turn the page
and you're saying perhaps what what did
you make of Odell saying it was personal
that the Giants trade him because it was
personal not because it was I think I
was like because it was it was personal
it was personal I'm okay with that meet
you
it's it's like who do you want in a
cover it doll it what's personal oh yeah
oh yeah he said that you you know I said
he wasn't their brand that was when he
said that he he was their player the
joins brand he wasn't the Giants brand
the Giants the New York Giants brand has
never been somebody like Odell Beckham
before okay okay what I'm saying is he
definitely kept them relevant that's for
sure I mean Loras Taylor was kind of in
the same mold in the things that he did
and how he was now he's the greatest
offensive player ever maybe what I'm
talking ever he never proposed to
kicking nets and stuff like that and
lifted his leg as a celebration let's
say we don't see it because we may have
as many cameras it's upon following
people at that point in time that's fine
we don't know what they did back then I
agree with you and I'm and i'ma say now
cuz I know those guys they did something
like that I'm telling you there was some
stuff going on but but I must say this
rich they they just had a problem with
him and his honesty and his willingness
to challenge teammates by the things he
had to say I must say mainly Eli it was
a lot of it was a lot he had he had a
lot to say about Eli he had a lot to say
about management and in the things that
they did and as players we accept it
when we are criticized we accept it when
people write about it we
except that on the shows when you talk
about us but GM's and owners they are
sensitive and they don't want to be
talked about unless it's winning and
doing great and when they mess up and
you talk about them it's bad you're not
supposed to it's not a level playing
field do you think Eli plays all 16 does
Eli play all 16 games this year for the
New York Football Giants Marshall Faulk
III can't based on the history of what
the Giants organization what they do
right or better yet what they did to my
very own Kurt Warner who had a winning
record before they replaced him with Eli
right I mean isn't it amazing all circle
is full circle who wouldn't that be
amazing and guess what Eli is gonna take
a like a champ by curtain has it he has
not say said one thing about it that's
correct and and and that's just who he
is that's his character so then the
answer is he will not place a cut I
can't see him playing 16 games I I don't
think this team and I could be wrong but
I don't think this team is ready to
compete and and in May obviously what
you do love stake one though right
Oh without a doubt yeah without a doubt
he's there saving grace in that regard
the whole thing well you gotta have some
grace to save it cuz Odell's in
Cleveland right the kid will be out
there by him lost by his lonesome that's
it's hard did you have a piece of
equipment that you could not do without
like Antonio Brown very similar the shut
helmet that that he I believe he was
wearing I wore that and and I was just
like man I'd have an issue I would I
would have an issue with that I mean I
wore a helmet or something like it right
pretty much my whole football career
right not just pro I'm talking college
right high school was it this it wasn't
the same helmet though not the same home
did you take the same helmet from
Indianapolis to st. Louis the same
actual helmet no not that no because
apparently that's what Antonio did
taking
same helmet from Pittsburgh and he hands
it to the Raiders saying make this into
a Raider helmet and they couldn't
because it was a discontinued helmet ten
years old yeah yeah they might make the
helmets anymore right yeah that's so do
you understand what he's doing uh or you
think I understand the comfort in which
he wants to play with like right I get
that I understand that
I just um you know there there has to be
some type of way that if a player wants
to wear something mm-hmm he gets to wear
it even if it's even if it's
discontinued and not as safe as what
other potential helmets he can wear it
sign a waiver that if anything happens
to you in this helmet or better yet you
can never be part of any concussion
medical issues needed beyond when you're
done then do so but I mean why why must
why must there be a winner and a loser
in this situation well I mean isn't the
winner the one who's getting his head
protected right well that's what I'm
saying his hair protected is is under
the assumption that it's going to be for
him he thinks exactly what you'd be he
think his head is protected in that
helmet well I also think that uh he
probably thinks he's safer cuz vantes
perfect as his teammate now that's I
would love the season set that is yeah
with incognito is the one who's required
all down Wow like just those three who's
you're up what right now your old Raider
stuff right where's Matuszak your your
first blush or your belief in who wins
the Super Bowl makes it and wins it
makes it you cannot not put Tom Brady in
there that we just should we just show
him in right
I can't what about the meap's getting
pulling it together again push the same
rock up that same Hill I
I just I have to see defensively I need
to see what that's going to look like
okay I'm on Tyrann Mathieu should make
him better right when do you think the
coordinator gotcha okay you know he had
that year with the Giants and that
defensive one hasn't been the same
anywhere else
he's been but he's been a bunch of
places since okay and so you like the
Patriots and I just yeah the night FC
it's hard to be billed and Tom I think
he's gonna go in the direction that I'm
thinking it going and I see in the NFC
the Saints it's I'm just trying to
figure out there playing with a whole
nother purpose because of how last year
ended I'm in the year before that too
yeah last two years yeah but but last
year was was two years ago was like
something happened last year they feel
like they got robbed what if a certain
somebody comes off of Cabo in time to
play all 16 games there's a chance there
but these holdouts it's a they affect
teams they affect that they actually
affect the nucleus of your team because
if I'm if and I'll be honest with you if
I'm Zeke and I was sitting down and I
saw that these Jaylon Smith hmm
I'm pissed well he says there's less pie
now for everybody yeah I'm just saying
I'm pissed on their business stop right
exactly but I mean you did hear them say
yeah we're taking some time off from
talking the name well why conduct
business it's all I came you know that I
thought hey and we love it are you love
and you're heading there now
I'm on my way there I have oh yeah I
have a bet he's been his kid been
busting his butt training hmm so you
know I got some I got some drills and
some stuff that I used to do cuz I
played whole games it wasn't no tap you
know I you know I get when I see tapping
out right so so you know i I've
challenged him with this conditioning
and and and trying to get him closer to
football ready not just being in good
shape Zeke so I'm going down to try to
make him throw up
my job so the over-under is one half of
a yak oh I'm gonna get him you can take
any over oh my god am i I got it I gotta
make him throw up great to see you here
bro same here man you know you were
there anytime you know give the man
that's Marshall Faulk Pro Football Hall
of Famer four more of the Rich Eisen
show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app